there's been this arc to my career in
the sense that in the beginning I just
wanted to make beautiful pictures but I
began more and more to see all these
problems happening in the ocean fewer
fish in the places I used to see many
fish or not as many sharks wouldn't go
out looking for sharks and I started to
see a need to tell those stories as well
you know I didn't think that most people
recognized the decline what was
happening in the ocean as a journalist I
saw that I had a responsibility to tell
those and I sensed a sense of urgency to
tell those stories as well I wanted to
get that out there and began doing
stories about problems in the ocean and
and hopefully offering solutions as well
as a way to to maybe move that dial a
little bit in favor of conservation if
somebody had told me when I started
diving back in 1977 that within a couple
of decades a few decades in my lifetime
I would have seen this this seismic
shift this dramatic loss of marine life
I wouldn't have believed it I didn't
think it was possible when I was 14 or
15 years old that the ocean couldn't
possibly lose that much in such a short
span of time problem is the ocean
suffers from this terrible fate of
having a beautiful exterior her finest
silks are on view and we go to the beach
where we go sailing but very few people
know what's happening below those waves
unless you're poking your head under
that water on a regular basis you might
not see that dramatic change everything
seems to be fine but it's not I believe
the good news is that it's not too late
there is still hope and there's still
ten percent of the sharks left of all
species and there's half the coral reefs
left so what we need to do is preserve
what remains
I think the ocean has the ability to
heal itself it is resilient it can be
restored I've seen this happen in places
where protection has been given we have
to be good custodians we have to do the
right thing we can't just keep doing
what we're doing because we're at a
pivotal moment in history where if we
let it slip through our fingers you know
it'll be us who pays the price when you
consider how tied we are to the ocean
every other breath that a human being
takes comes from the see that it's
vitally important to our own existence
in the end when we save the ocean we're
saving ourselves that's a pretty good
motivator for for doing the right thing
[Music]
[Music]